but uh um i i want to i want to get into
the the fed overreaching all stuff
because um
we we briefly mentioned james o'keefe
guys
i got a conspiracy theory for you yes
you ready for a conspiracy thing
yeah i think you will agree with me on
the plausibility of this conspiracy alex
is a fed
no no
that james o'keefe was investigating the
fbi so they rated him to try and seize
the evidence
let me let me lay out my case oh this is
a no-brainer the f right the fbi raids
james o'keefe and project veritas and
james
himself and his home and his journalists
they claim it's over some diary that he
turned over to the law enforcement a
long time ago so this is what are they
searching for a diary he gave away
already okay within an hour or so of the
raid the new york times calls for
comment on some of these journalists
meaning someone tipped off the new york
times
information electronic devices were
seized from james o'keefe
privileged legal communications were
then leaked to the new york times it is
widely believed the fbi were leaking
privileged communications to the new
york times the new york times stated
that in those communications james
o'keefe was discussing with his lawyer
the extent to which they could
undercover record federal law
enforcement
on october 20th i believe it was uh an
fbi whistleblower sent documents to the
republicans outlining how merrick
garland was using counter-terror tactics
against parents right the fbi must have
found out and this is my theory my
hypothesis that they had a leaker within
the within the bureau and that james
o'keefe i believe they knew someone was
communicating with him but they didn't
know what he was given
so they said we can't let him release
this
so they rated him under false pretext
seized his communications
activists within the bureau said give it
to the new york times and destroy them
that's my theory i would even add that
they probably were the ones that gave
him the diary in the first place since
this diary was going around and they
didn't explain trap yeah and they didn't
expect them to give it to to law
enforcement which project veritas did
they didn't run with the story and uh i
just think they were extremely desperate
this isn't even a conspiracy theory at
this point i don't think this all makes
perfect sense to me like the fact that
this got leaked when it did the fact
that they raided his house the fact that
he didn't even have the diary but they
assumed he would because i guess that's
what they would have done if they'd been
in his position
this isn't a conspiracy theory to me
this just sounds to me like what
happened
and october so i don't know when the
leak happened so this is a correction
fox news reports an october 20th
internal email from the fbi's criminal
encounter terror divisions released
tuesday by house republicans instructed
agents to apply the threat tag edu
officials to all investigations and
assessments of threats directed
specifically at education officials
could it be and this is we will issue an
update in correction it wasn't that the
fbi whistleblower set the information on
the 20th
what if this fbi whistleblower went to
veritas first
following the raid by the fbi earlier
this month the whistleblower then
brought it to the republicans
interesting
i think the fbi went after james o'keefe
because they were scared that o'keefe
had information on them and i will
stress the new york times said in the
legal communications that veritas was
asking about the extent to which they
could secretly record fbi agents
yeah i i think this is this is legit
dude i mean it's still conspiracy
specification
because there's no no evidence or well
there's some i guess you could call it
evidence but there's no proof in any way
so we're still theorizing but i mean
james that's what the fbi does james
wouldn't know you didn't think they in
in
james might know when they did they set
up uh the whole what was it the michigan
governor yeah the fbi plainly like i
don't know if they admitted to it or
what but they were like forced causing
that to happen you have and before
social media if this was 20 years ago
all of this would sound ridiculous and
crazy well now there's enough evidence
in a paper trail that people are like
all right this is plausible well 28
years ago we had the fbi scandal with
the 1993
world trade center uh bombing which also
put them in a very questionable
situation so when you look at the
history of the fbi call hotel probe uh
and and all the other things that they
have done there's a long history of
doing things that were absolutely
illegal in the name of fighting the law
right so this is nothing new
what the fbi has been up to throughout
their entire existence anyway
this is scary and and uh nightmarish
reality you know it's like uh it's like
we were in the matrix the whole time you
know you're talking about how 20 years
ago we went to figure this out but the
internet basically
for lack of a better term red pilled
everybody yes
and now they're all watching it happen
from the outside like oh dear lord this
is horrifying yeah yeah i feel like the
humanity's been under the boot since the
beginning and then the founding fathers
were like yo
the the war they didn't actually well
washington fought but
that sacrifice to kind of get us out
from under the boot but at what point
did they they all sacrificed
they all did each and every one of
franklin's sons joined the british oh of
course they sacrificed they they they
staked their what did they say their
their blood their treasure and their
sacred honor or whatever there was a one
founding father's wife was taken
prisoner to be used in a prisoner
exchange a good majority of their homes
were under british occupation shout out
to the founding mothers man just think
about this especially fancy the the
signers of declaration of independence
who who sat down and could have just
went guys it's a tax it sucks but i want
to make sure my kids have food so i'm
not going to war and i will i will throw
it to mel gibson in one of the best
movies ever the patriot where he says is
that the one he hears with the beaver
the beaver no no the patriot is a it's a
long movie about him getting revenge for
the british soldiers killing himself
okay
amazing movie and he's in south carolina
he's in ch i think charleston and he
says if you're asking me if i think
taxation without representation is wrong
i agree with you but if you're asking me
to go to war with england i say no and
then the british go to his house seeking
rebels soldiers he's tending aid to all
of them and his son was a writer for the
for the american revolutionaries so he's
like who is this man who are these
orders and then mel gibson's one of his
kids got a bunch of kids runs to try and
save the older brothers being arrested
and the the the british officer shoots
and kills them right mel gibson then
uses his rep like his american frontier
war cup training and goes on like a
one-man but not one man he's like a
group of militiamen and he goes and
starts raiding uh the british anyway i
digress that that that was an excellent
scene where you see a guy who doesn't
want to fight he doesn't want to go to
war
then i think back to the founding
fathers and what really happened they
all said from young ages of like what 26
to like like 50s or whatever
i will say to the king
i declare war on you and you know what's
funny you know what's really funny and i
say funny and not in the hallway they
knew they believed we'd lose the
founding fathers thought war with
britain would never play off and they
would lose but the french intervention
saved us so these were guys who were
like i am so pissed off at them
quartering in our homes taking our
belongings
telling us we can't defend ourselves
that i am willing to say i will fight
you and lose
even if it means my children and at the
time england had the biggest military in
the world they were the biggest might
they were the biggest power and uh that
movie along with braveheart tells a very
similar story absolutely has your love
pumping and motivates you and really
shows you the larger consequences of
what is routine in human history and
it's not an exception to the rule it is
the rule and the other thing that
they're not taught in a high school
civics class is how what a huge
percentage of the american population
were loyalists that's right that they
wanted nothing to do with this nonsense
we're loyal british subjects shut the f
up george washington leave us alone
you're making we're not revolutionaries
this is crazy so victory is never a
function of persuading the majority
they're always going to follow the
leaders so i've read i've tried to do a
lot of i've done a decent amount of
research not a historian probably people
know better than me on the percentages
of
so yeah i've looked into it there's a
famous um misconception where i think it
was ben franklin someone said a third
are loyalists a third are uh you know
one independence and a third want to be
left alone but that's not actual numbers
so i looked i looked it up and the best
assessment i could find is that
the plurality
uh wanted nothing to do with anyone the
plurality said shut up and leave me
alone and go away the next largest group
was in like the 30 percentile which said
we want independence and then in the 20
high 20th you know percentages were
people saying long live the king
all that mattered was those who actually
cared the so the people who were
uninitiated leave me alone abstained
the revolution won the vote basically
and the other question about this is
really interesting when it came to
voting on whether declare independence a
lot of colonists were they were british
they all consider themselves british
they said by what authority do you
declare independence the name of our
state yeah they said who elected you to
go there and say you're a representative
of a free state of virginia they just
did this they were like ad hoc pop-ups
of people being like we hereby we hereby
declare and then they sent the letter to
the king and the king was like but
people need to understand is the
revolution was over 20 years
the regulars the british regulars were
coming here and getting into conflicts
and doing right control and getting shot
at and shooting back for for decades so
it wasn't just one day they said we
hereby declare independence here's a
letter and then the king said send to
the troops the troops were there they
were fighting and then within i think it
was like 1865 is when sentiment started
rising and we started seeing conflicts
65 1765 and then 1776 is when they're
like we are now asserting our
independence outright over 20 years this
process took place and then it was what
another decade or so before the bill of
rights right so it was a long but it's
also funny when it's like the king gets
the declarations like that's it i'm
setting in the troops like one month
later
i gotta wait for them to cross the
atlanta check this out i talk about this
quite a bit
they all gather uh so so all these
founding fathers are sending letters to
each other and it takes a few weeks for
the letter to arrive in virginia and
then to go back so the communication
around independence is taking years they
have their their con continental
congress they have their meetings and
they say okay we we're going to send a
letter to the king with our list of
demands because they sent demand letters
first several
how long did it take to get back to the
to the king three months by sale then
the king responds three months later so
six months for one question yeah yeah
yeah one question and then a year goes
by and then i i'm like i'm thinking i
i've talked about how funny it is you
know you know he's like uh thomas
jefferson says we hereby declare
independence ha ha
they fold it up hand it to the guy he
gets on his horse he rides to the boat
everyone goes back to work they go farm
and they forget all about it and then a
year later a boat arrives and they're
like look big british vessels are coming
and they're angry with us for some
reason oh yeah that letter
[Laughter]
god dammit hancock it's like it's like
no no thomas jefferson is like he's like
did i send a letter last night i was
drunk
i was with sally in the barn
show up they're bombarding the coast and
they're like remember that night a year
ago we all got drunk and we're like
i think we should be independent
i'm gonna write a letter yeah you write
a letter to the king you tell them and
they all sign it and they're like cheers
i can't even read your signature
wait you actually mailed it that was
supposed to be a joke i thought you were
just letting off steam
right right right you're supposed to not
send the you write the letter but don't
send it okay yeah that's there would be
every session i'm just imagining the
king like three months later gets the
declaration of independence and he's
like
they've they've already been acting as
an independent country for three months
you know so then he's like okay i guess
you know go quell the revolution and
then he's like what a coincidence this
would be dated the same day as
independence day that's right that's so
strong that was the weirdest part that
was the weirdest part you know um my
understanding is independence day was
july 2nd
right nice yeah why did we choose i
don't remember there's like this this
like trivia thing they say did you know
the signing was the second but it wasn't
until like they didn't they have to wait
for a couple signers or something i
don't remember i think it was like they
mailed it out uh you know on the fourth
or whatever or something like that so
i don't know if that's true but i
remember reading there was a quote from
like john adams was like july 2nd will
be the day that america declared
independence and it's july 4. so we have
the boot on the neck now kind of right
in the metaphor is it like the global
banking system and we're like we will
use bitcoin and all crypto and that's
our way of saying we don't respect your
authority king george yeah i would say
so for sure not using fiat money yeah i
think people need to realize that as
much as we can talk about the founding
fathers saying like hurrah and then
taking up arms we're not in that air
anymore you know first of all we're
joking about the time gap between
sending a message now you can literally
be like yo we declare independence mf or
haha and like they'll give anything's
trigger it all happens everything's
ready to go like emf your phone yeah
everything starts to trigger fifth
generational warfare is the most
important point
the liberty-minded individuals the
whatever you want to call this group
have been winning because we've been
very persuasive and peaceful when black
lives matter rioted black lives matter
lost
tons of support among the politically
uninitiated when we when we start
winning hearts and minds and change the
culture that's how we actually win and
you don't win by freaking people out
with violence violence is wrong so what
did what effect did january 6 have on
people not the media it empowers the
federal government to create a national
capital police force and torture people
right and you get 80 million people
going like oh no an insurrection and
he's politically uninitiated by intuit
so i often tell people there's a there's
a funny episode of frasier i saw a long
time ago i don't watch frasier but it
was when i was a kid where something
happens where um frasier is is sitting
down for coffee he gets up someone takes
his seat he gets angry and says this is
my seat i was sitting here and the guy
says shove off frazier having a bad day
grabs him and throws him out of the seat
yeah very angry so the guy comes back
one day with like a neck brace and he's
like i'm suing you because you accosted
me and then frasier's like oh no it's a
big lawsuit at the end of the episode
he's at the cafe trying to apologize to
the guy i could be getting the show
wrong with the gist of it is here he's
trying to apologize to the guy saying
look i shouldn't have done that too i'm
really really sorry please drop the suit
and the guy says no and then niles
frazier's brother gets up in between and
says you listen here you [ __ ] you
don't do that you know to my brother you
imbecile and so the guy says no no you
listen to me and then pokes his chest
lightly and then niles goes
and falls over and slams into a table
full of like silverware and he goes
countersuit counter suit perfect and
then the guy drops his lawsuit the point
of that story is niles goes to federal
prison
no the guy attacked him he was like i
didn't do anything and they're like we
all saw you touch him you pushed him so
when you look at what's going on with
antifa violence
we might be upset that the feds aren't
charging these people but rest assured
regular americans saw all of that and
one by one they started figuring out
what was going on now the media
narrative was strong and a lot of people
didn't realize the truth about the
written house case but now we're seeing
the young turks we're seeing chris hayes
we're seeing professionalism chris hayes
said in all likelihood he said i've been
looking at the case and uh it looks like
an acquittal in all honesty yeah wait
just just cause he's predicting
acquittal doesn't mean he thinks the
guy's not guilty no no no i'm not saying
he said right now is not guilty i'm
saying his attitude is now he's going to
get acquitted versus he's this you know
like he's put like it's a lightening on
the narrative got it okay and a
conspiracy that i was wrong about what
happened okay progressives are tweeting
i didn't realize what had actually
happened so the more we're persuasive
the more we're correct and the more that
the corporate press is uh dishonest
because if there's a big asymmetry i
make this point all the time if i tell
you tim my friend like 10 truths and one
lie those are not equal weight
especially if the lie is this egregious
when there's this kid on trial who's 17
years old who's crying and then you're
laughing at his ptsd that's right
so i think there are a lot of i think
most people want safety security peace
they want to live their lives they want
to pursue their goals and they're not
really interested in politics
and so when they see the mainstream
media that corporate press say x y and z
they say yeah yeah x y and z i get it
but then one day x y and z don't equal
one two and three and they start getting
confused yes and it keeps piling on and
piling on and piling on but when you get
a january six that reinforces the the
narrative from the corporate press from
the cathedral the establishment so we
need to make sure
if we tell if we if we are saying ten
things and we are all honest individuals
trying our hardest but we get one wrong
people will say oh they they talk they
made some bad predictions but the stuff
they said i found out to be true the
media is an inversion of this yes they
say ten things and nine things are wrong
and people finally get fed up and say
this is bs they're lying to me and then
they say i come to you for a solution
yeah so we were talking about how you
would weight something like a moral
weight whether someone does something
bad and one and luke brought up henry
kissinger and i was going to say one of
the things that we should take into
account is whether or not this is a
pattern and i would say that this is the
same case with the media if they're
making a pattern of lying to us
egregiously about everything all the
time then they decide maybe they might
throw in a truth every now and then we
can say
you are full of nonsense so what ends up
happening those uninitiated individuals
who aren't paying attention are starting
to ask questions about whether gas is so
high yeah why they can't buy turkeys
because the price of turkey is double
and why are you telling me this is a
good thing right right or this is a rich
people problem oh yeah and then what
happens a truck driver in new jersey
wins his election against the incumbent
democrat after only spending 153 bucks
because we're getting to the point where
people will elect a ham sandwich over
and establish this also happened with
dave ball when he took out eric cantor
the house majority leader at the time
that no one saw coming
when was that one was that that was when
was that that was during the obama
administration thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you